so take us to that moment I'm sitting at
home my jaw dropped you see the ball
what are you thinking in that moment
take us there
yeah man a lot of things happen crazy uh
real fast but uh I just kind of saw the
ball come off his leg I kind of kicked
it and I just ran after him man I got a
good bounce man and after that it's just
kind of like middle school I just pick
it up kind of squawful because you can
um I got a good block from I got Mike
and uh man I was just into the End Zone
after that middle school but Nick could
you even believe that that was happening
that it would be right there in front of
you could you even believe that that had
happened
yeah man uh man it's just a real moment
man uh yeah the ball just kind of kind
of got kind of came out of my way and
got a lucky bounce man and uh again it
hopped right in my chest man after that
man it's just I just gotta take
advantage of it man it was a big moment
uh for us as a team and um we needed
that one in order to get the win
I mean more of the lucky balance uh Nick
you're putting pressure uh on the
quarterback there Jalen hurts forcing
that fumble and then I I'm really
curious to know you mentioned like it's
Middle School do you feel like a kid
today I mean you just won the Super Bowl
yeah man uh you're watching this game
going up man it's kind of crazy man not
even just playing in it uh you watched
it off for the last 10 12 years and um
just being enjoying it with your family
man and all the good events that comes
with it man so just playing in it and uh
getting getting a chance to make that
play Man in that moment man uh it's
pivotal for us man we needed it uh we
ended up going 10 down 10 at halftime
and still find a way to find a way to
win man uh it's a gritty wind man just
part of my team part of my coaches man
sticking to it I'll find a way to win
hey Nick you've said that you don't feel
any pressure when it comes to playing on
the field and you've said that in
response to the battle and struggle that
you saw your mother and sister fight
your mom with breast cancer your sister
with brain cancer how has their
struggles helped shape you into the man
and player you are today yeah man uh I
think on football in terms of football
man I think it's kind of a privilege to
be able to play this game man and play
at this level uh a lot of people want to
play at this level so I kind of take it
as that and um I don't really see
pressure around the rooms of football
man because uh I've seen pressure where
where you didn't have no no the next
meal is going to be or things like that
so uh in terms of football man um this
is just uh the thing we do for leisure
men's having fun man you know they're
trying to live at a moment enjoy it well
we saw a very emotional moment I think
everybody was touched by this you and
your mom together it was a very
emotional greeting between the two of
you
take it take us there too what were you
guys saying
clearly a lot of love there oh man
yeah uh just uh man she was proud of me
man I was just uh part of what became uh
from from
a lot of hard times man
um there's a lot of Tears man just to
finally be the win and being top and
feel like all the stuff you went through
man it's worthwhile
um and it was special especially
spending with her she wasn't able to
watch my state championship game in uh
Texas yeah last time I had a chance of
playing a game of that magnitude and so
uh Urban and that stands and uh being
there man uh it was very very special
for me well Nick Bolton man oh man you
are the man thank you so much for
joining us this morning have a great day
it's off to a very good start yeah
thank you man I appreciate it